like even how to tell girls stuff
certain things like guys would be like
yo you stink like ass go and take a
shower I would tell my friends like yo
it's a little onion in here and they be
like oh yeah my bad dog so we had a
girl at work she couldn't smell at all
it's not from Co I think she hit her
head in skateboard or something so she
couldn't smell she couldn't smell so it
was her first day and she's like hey
guys and it was like just onion what it
was been a week so far and it started
lingering ah and the girls came up to me
and like yo you're the shift leader you
got to take care of it and I was like
I'm the only dude hereo I can't tell her
anything I was like you girls got to
tell her like no we can't we're in no
position to do it kind of got you there
so I'm going to take it to the manager
and the manager was a girl so I was like
you got to tell her something cuz like
that's unhealthy for our workspace and
as soon as the manager talked to her you
saw her coming out just cry so she
didn't do it the right way there was no
right way honestly my question to you
guys is how do you
say